you or someone you care about may have
been diagnosed with head and neck cancer
this video will help you understand how
it can be managed
the most common type of head and neck
cancer called squamous cell carcinoma is
a disease where cancer cells form inside
the nose sinuses mouth throat voice box
or salivary glands
treatment for head and neck cancer May
remove or destroy the cancer but
treatment may affect your ability to
speak eat or swallow depending on the
location of the cancer
you may need Rehabilitation or
reconstructive surgery to preserve or
restore function so you can return to
activities as soon as possible after
treatment
for example if you have problems
speaking or swallowing a speech-language
pathologist can help you with swallowing
exercises or speech therapy
after treatment it's very important to
have a follow-up care plan
this includes going to follow-up
appointments
your doctor will want to check for any
signs of the cancer returning and check
for health problems that may have
resulted from treatment
your doctor May order lab tests or
Imaging tests like MRIs or CT scans to
check for cancer
if you are on any medications continue
to take them as prescribed by your
doctor
take note of any side effects and tell
your doctor
if you had surgery or other treatments
follow any instructions you were given
there are lifestyle changes that can
improve your health and help you feel
better
it's important to quit smoking this
lowers the risk for cancer returning or
spreading
limiting how much alcohol you drink May
reduce your risk of cancer
eat a healthy diet with more fruits
vegetables and whole grains this may
also reduce your risk of certain cancers
become Physically Active activities like
walking riding a bicycle or swimming can
help you feel better and less tired
talk to your doctor before starting an
exercise routine
knowing you have cancer can be
overwhelming you may have worries about
your condition and how it affects your
family
treatments and hospital stays
medical bills and your job
there are ways to help you cope with
this
remember that your doctor and Health
Care team are there to answer any
questions you have
the following sources of support can
help you cope with your concerns
social workers
Faith leaders
counselors
and support groups
talk to your doctor if you have any
questions about your treatment plan
medications or lifestyle changes to help
you manage head and neck cancer